now look that's that right yeah but RAM
is really completely let's check out the
last map and maybe we'll do like a
montage where we train and have awesome
music in the background and then we
return oh this is pretty fancy I think
this definitely looks completable and
from a scale from one to ten I'd say
three and a half
Oh wonderful look forward to this huh
hey I didn't cry
very handsome as always of course hey we
had you have a little switchblade yeah
all right cool I was so sad I like how
you look with it yeah yeah change for
you when I do this no no all right
I wish oh I like this oh there's a guy
over there oh there is
yeah it's staying in you can awkwardly
okay but wait I'm pretty pretty ladies
you look like cattle right now I did
yeah but whatever you need to do that
man like thank you okay all right wait
waiting and so you can really got it
time this sledgehammer and a test and
there we go that's how we're all okay
with it I found it
Oh shot gun I'll let you have that
running oh hey there's a one of these
things oh oh there's just like yeah this
is what is this thing another one
I guess all right
so many well that's another one there's
another one okay everyone stand back
shoot him Chuck wait I want to do the
sledgehammer attack that was pretty neat
yeah is it working yes one more right
another yes there we go there we go
so proud of you yes thank you all right
practice makes perfect
what I do in fact oh no no wait all
right okay oh I don't think we got to
deal with the saga anymore at least yes
I guess you have the shotgun to you
think yeah the fruits of our Labor's is
we can actually not die where is are we
going I mean I don't know there's
nothing
oh that's how about wrong
yes oh stop shooting it no one likes you
you know that no one not even cry likes
you not that guys jerk
maybe that's not cool no okay
good news you grades that we don't have
and throw them all right I'm throwing
them good job Bob I think it's good you
got good we should let him out and then
just try to run past them
you're a genius I know right it's good
Lewbert
all right you're nuts [ __ ] that good a
bullet oh yeah oh yeah this gun - come
here Simon
I'm almost dead this is bad me too
crap I'm so tryharding in the epidemic I
don't know how much can no I'm out of
ammo I don't think you can kill him
all right die on me again I I might have
fallen down and I can't get up I got
your back
let that's my front but thank you sir oh
boy
there we go not too proud Oh like it's
not even looking it's like I'll let you
have this one okay it went dark the
confusion is actually happiness that's
the emotion you're feeling oh but did we
kill em or didn't we
oh no the babies the babies babies yes I
don't want babies don't go that I don't
have enough responsibility in my brain
to handle babies we try to save you okay
all right that's pretty now see okay all
right you say that no I told you stop
hitting me it's not true
that's right I forgot to do sound
effects all right always make it better
then not another one all right take that
there we go
nice girl hi it's guys
Oh God about German so much
hey we should play video game
Oh what kind of video game I shouldn't a
curve you play that game yeah dude it
again it was beautiful
ok I think someone's being assaulted by
a dog
really that's more than finding the head
I'm in the bidet game
don't mind the nipple there we go
dangerous got a lot of em and I been
pretty bad I think that we're just too
strong oh that exploded hey that guy's
not doing it right
that's not how you walk look right why
are you so weak will help I can't die
now
oh good maybe he was there anybody then
we're the ones doing it wrong that
explains why I'm the one that's dead
good point man it was still as health
what song yeah yeah exactly
gonna come around
yeah
what is this a coca-cola and is useless
just drinkin hey can we pay thank you
oh this room is pointless it really was
a reward going backwards because I can't
really tell
I don't know no this is correct okay I
think we're not gonna make it but I
believe for the most part that we'll
make it for a little bit
yep nope we'll make it okay it's dark
and creepy car that I'll make it for
sure I'm guessing you're here
no just the VP I'll take that okay wait
I have so much on my mind as well go
with it hello what are you doing are you
okay there I know all right think you
weren't either though did I walk in
circles no uh-uh
it's here okay oh this thing okay there
we go very acrobatic I know right hey
but pardon the tribe where do you have
to jump I was getting so frustrated out
of that freely yes oh god that was this
one jump I just could not do it and I
watched another let's play do it and he
just did it the first time not like any
problem at all I was like wow yeah I did
too actually
all right Oh cry say what save you break
Bobby don't die now oh okay I have a
knife you don't have any animals no no
I'm a why did I think on the Amazon I
thought you have a shotgun
it was at a shot Oh
oh man maybe doing what maybe we're
starting at the good point
I'm hoping we do yeah this is yes that's
what it was
except we don't have all the groupies
done but I have mo again I miss the
sledgehammer so much right now
sweet sledgehammer what are you doing
there
nice double shot thank you
so this is the puzzle part if I remember
yeah God do we have to do puzzles again
ever redo the same puzzle I don't even
remember it I want to try a knife or
knife ruin this one that's right that's
right that's right
I know what you gonna do buy it huh what
you gonna do there we go Oh
not bad right not bad how do you have
the next one
No ah right there go bring it back
all right I got this I like how they're
politely standing in line for you there
we go
hey not bad not bad huh is it better to
stab them and slice them yeah and also
looks more bad right yeah it does
while you kill things all right then I
come in we can actually kill these
people
awesome and we can enjoy this bird oh
it's an out okay I guess its second here
bird I thought that tree branch was like
something Hey look up there right you
see the dancing yeah they're like oh
they're arriving let's start dancing
it's the welcoming dance there's one
tooth I hear someone fapping
alright see walking okay I get those
mixed up something nice horse horse
Tellez are your secrets how do we kill
these people
you all right yeah why do you ignore us
I don't get it you were so cool back in
the day I know why okay I guess it's
your turn hello got right even try it's
like uh so tired whatever
[Music]
[Music]
it's